the robb elementary school has now taken
its place alongside sandy hook columbine
parkland
yet another school shooting to haunt
america this time primary school-aged
children killed in their classroom
the faces and the names are different
but this has become an awful fact of
life in america
the first of the victims to be
identified was teacher eva moreles
herself a mother wife of a policeman a
career educator who was very loved
according to her family
the white house flag was lowered to
mourn the lives taken
a president and his wife a teacher
herself of course wrestling with the
horror and the helplessness
in elementary school
beautiful
innocent
second third fourth graders
and how many scores of little children
who witness what happened
see their friends die
as if they're on a battlefield for god's
sake
when in god's name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
this is the gunman who was responsible
salvador ramos bought the rifles on his
18th birthday he crashed his car before
entering the school around midday moving
between the classrooms until he was shot
dead by a police officer
my heart was broken today
we're a small community
and we will need your prayers to get us
through this
uvaldi in texas is now the scene of the
deadliest primary school shooting since
sandy hook almost 10 years ago
many believe that massacre of six and
seven year olds would change everything
it shames america that nothing has
changed
but once again the calls for gun control
come
by doing something
we at least
stop sending this quiet message
of endorsement
to these killers whose brains are
breaking who see the highest levels of
government doing nothing
the grief is unimaginable for the
families of uvalde but this is the 27th
school shooting this year in the united
states
a country wondering what it will take
for anything to ever change